i'm at the great pyramid of giza
you better go that kid's gonna beat you
trying to beat the group so i can film
this thing it's a one-shot deal
that's how it's done hello
welcome welcome
hello
i'm inside the great pyramid as you can
see
obviously not the original tunnel let's
be crystal clear on that
oh
okay
oh look at this sucker
it's always important to remember these
stairs were not here
would have just been a smooth shaft
it appears to be still bedrock
no those are cut blocks
okay keep going
wow okay
this grand gallery is different than i
thought down there goes i think to the
queen's chamber
you're doing good nick i guess i just
have to step up here
i don't know
wow this is
this is big in the slant of it the angle
of it
is different than i thought
[Music]
dude echo
i can do this thing with my tongue
it's annoying as hell but it's loud
because i needed the shot i ditched the
group
and [ __ ] ran part of my language all
the way to the top steps
so i could bring all of you my lovely
loyal following or viewers or whoever's
watching this
the shot that i need which is a tour of
the great pyramid of giza
and here i am after sunset
i believe it's almost 30 feet high here
in the grand gallery
some 150 feet long
[Music]
and then this is the angle that this is
going at i just didn't realize
like i mean i'm climbing up what's that
yeah and keep in mind there's no
without these man-made steps this won't
even be doable
just be sliding down
okay
i'm out of breath wow
rose granite from a thousand kilometers
away
more than 600 miles razor
look we got a camera here
looks like it's brand new nick say hello
you're going on youtube my friend oh
yeah
i'm on the great pyramid of giza this is
surreal
i've waited years for this but yeah look
at the precision
hold on 100 times bigger than the other
two
yeah this makes the other pyramids look
like
small nothings all right i'm gonna keep
going
now we're going down in here
i don't know what this goes i can't see
anything
okay now you're up look at this
this little relief chamber
again on 5 foot 10 i've mentioned this
in multiple videos
and my hand doesn't barely reach the top
of that
blocks okay look
geez
okay
away we go
oh my god i am alone
inside the so-called king's chamber
of the great pyramid of giza egypt
consisting of some
of hundreds of 70-ton blocks
that are in making up this chamber and
right above us that you cannot see
[Music]
i'm popping in that's what i'm doing
i'm in the box let's lay down my head
i don't know if you can see me
[Music]
that's my view kind of creepy
i'm in here alone this is such a
blessing
i won't get all sentimental
jesus can you see that
laser-like cut precision
and proof of loss technology right here
located air conditioning units
my friend how's it feel to be inside the
great pyramid is this your first time in
here
get the film while you can everyone's
gonna be in here noisy
[Music]
yeah i'm gonna do this annoying thing
that i do but
precision yeah never stick your hand in
something in a desert
goes to the other airshaft
again it's huge huge huge blocks
i'm going back in henry will you sign
that light in here for me just so it
shows up on the camera
i'm filming this on the iphone 12 pro at
ultrawide 0.5
in case you're wondering
it's worth mentioning that this box okay
that's nice precision
this is all busted
i'm so excited
[Music]
especially since we can put us on the
internet everyone can yell at me for how
annoying i am
home videos jimmy's home videos
[Music]
that gallery grand gallery so-called
grand yellow gallery was something else
and again above us you have several
chambers
it gives us a 70 ton blocks and all
these things right above us
our 70 ton blocks rose granite
we're getting a thousand kilometers i
think some 500 miles
as would be the way of the nile
this is like the ultimate bathroom
that box would not fit for that door but
that's old news
and there could be multiple explanations
for that all right
and this in oh let me show you not all
of this is original
like this you can see it's like hanging
above
back here these are all busted out yet
but
just you don't think i'm making this up
any one of the reasons this topic
already knows this
but this is missing so was it this block
one of these blocks was pulled out
[Music]
and i'm not gonna stop filming it let it
roll
you're looking at it
i mean
[Music]
it's a little warm in here today is
december 11th
2020.
[Music]
i went to thinking youtube or no sitting
on the couch
not liking my job depressed went back to
school for an mba
it would make me a cushy job of money
sitting at a desk i was so depressed
i felt like going back to school to
become a teacher
well i felt like becoming a teacher i
had to do that i'd have to go back to
school i was
kidding me i'm going back to school
again
and then somehow i stumbled on the
youtube idea i'm like well i can
teach people from the internet i heard
you can make money on youtube but i
wasn't really familiar with how it all
worked
i started making videos all kinds of
topics spirituality
various conspiracies
all kinds of stuff and anyone that's
followed me since the beginning knows
what i'm talking about crazy topics to
do with some people might think about
stuff
but then i just hit the thing i was
making topics on all kinds of crazy
stuff
stuff and
i've actually decided to get on that
couch and start making videos on
ancient history you probably can't hear
me at all
i can tell my life story another time
but the point is this
we are creators and you can choose a
life for yourself
and now because of talking about these
topics it just made me happy i'm like
ancient history is fun
and it won't be hard to research it
because i enjoy it reading
won't feel like pain like some boring
topic in some textbook and schooly
subjects you don't care about but um
because if you love what you're doing
you do you love it feel like work was
the philosophy
and now so i focused on ancient history
stuff
and now just a few years later i'm on a
group tour here in
a great pyramid
guys you can do whatever you want you
just have to get off the couch show up
take actionable steps in the direction
you want to go i won't be so preachy i
already talked about this stuff in
another video when i posted to instagram
so i'll just go back and film some more
[Music]
oh no no thank you i'll wait a second
hey darryl
[Music]
i almost feel like jumping over here
thumbs up guys give me a thumbs up
i'm just gonna keep recording
[Music]
all right
just filming a tour
wow
oh i mean you're going to see this
position
when they say that you couldn't fit a
razor blade through it
that's what they mean i mean it's
literally like it's
i mean it's look at that
there's no mortar it's just
walk after block
[Music]
some people probably wonder what it's
like to walk around here you got to be
careful
we're going down i've done this with the
other pyramids because these the same
type of steps
you can pretty much stub your toe going
like this skip because it's kind of like
it's just little details
but again
[Music]
oh yes i'm not leaving just filming
thank you yousef i love you yusuf ayan
if you don't know yusuf ayan you're
missing out
he was trained by his father if you've
seen the pyramid code
you will be certainly the familiar
tribal legend
[Music]
so i don't know where this goes
oh this is open now this was closed
earlier
so perfect so this is that goes
down but as i came in the pyramid it
went up obviously
and this is where i had showed you
earlier that it was closed and locked to
the queen's chamber
so-called queen's chamber there was no
queen in there
so this is my first trip in here i'm
completely hunched over
as you can see legs are bent
and again okay just keep going you guys
want to see the tour
yeah this is a functional this isn't
i do not believe that this is a tomb or
at least not
constructed all right so it lifts up a
little bit i don't believe that this was
constructed
with the purpose of being a tomb and
that was used for that later on
this already possible but look at this
one
bot two block three block four block
there we go
all right i was not expecting to see
that
kind of weird smell in here
very similar at least for the roofing
compared to the middle pyramid coffer
i've mentioned and shared before
oh shoot i forgot to put this on
ultra wide oh well
see this is one thing i'd like to go in
hello
i'm gonna press stop recording real
quick just so i can go to ultra wide
hang tight you'll see i haven't gone
anywhere okay
see what a difference this makes
hopefully
i didn't ruin the video the other way
it makes things look more narrow but you
can see stuff
i'm surprised i didn't notice that i'm
having a good time though i was like
what's all this crap
all right
jimmy don't touch stuff
room service
wow
sticking my hand in a hole in the
pyramid
again look at that precision
people do the homework hear that
i'll try and do it
i guess i'll try to do it
[Music]
that's not working i haven't perfected
it
i'll stop that's not working
wow wow wow all right i'll take you
on the tour on the way out following him
you're not just figuring
me on social media come on in
you might be surprised at what you first
see in here
explosions no i'll just film your
reaction
nothing that you would expect to be
inside of a barren
queen's so-called queen's chamber
just the trashita furniture
[Music]
sigurdsson by the way
and does anyone have a light to flash in
your air conditioner
but you can see bring it on in here this
is very interesting
buddy
[Music]
now
hello
you can hear people doing their own
this is a vibrational powerhouse
that's coming from way up down beyond
the green gallery that is happening in
the king's chamber
this is not a tomb this thing was
functional
it's beyond our understanding i believe
it involves water
air and vibration i don't pretend to
have the answers because i
certainly don't but what i do know is
that
the tomb idea is quite silly no
disrespect to anyone that believes it
i know people yell at me and get mad at
me for even saying it but
it's not my fault you're wrong at least
i can admit i don't know what it is
[Music]
now once i come out i'm gonna come back
in and start filming
but you are getting an inside and out
tour of the green river
egypt on december 11 2020 just after
sunset oh what's up ben what's up
hey how are you doing you're on camera
brother what uh
what are you thinking yeah i love it
here i uh
i got down and went to the subterranean
chamber there's only just now
i've went been down and been back up is
it open yeah
there's one guy down there just uh i'm
going in
yeah do it take your torches it's dark
at the bottom
okay it's surreal this is the wave right
yeah open door
wow this is dark i can see
it's worth mentioning the 12 pro has
excellent low light visibility so with
something else you want to have this
luxury oh wow that's
okay that's far where does this go
it goes straight up look at this
in this dark color stone hold on here oh
that's more rose granite i believe
surrounded by the limestone
this is creepy you can see a slight
light
but i can't see i can't see a freaking
thing
this is almost uh i'm not scared
i wish i could turn on my camera
flashlight while recording but it
doesn't let me do it
yeah this is i can't even i don't know
how much further i should
keep in mind i can't even see the steps
in front of me at all
you can see this tiny little light
window whatever
okay now i can see a little bit better
jesus
i am having fun
wait is this even where does that go
okay
yeah can you see just the other
entrance way in far more
makes far more sense than the other way
that was blasted out
and dug out 100 plus years ago whatever
it was
oh wow this
is a workout
hello
this is this is awesome
forgive me if my narrations are annoying
i don't know how you sound by doing this
but
we're getting a shot
oh yeah let's let me just stop and show
you
well done i don't make them like they
used to
[Music]
i'm moving but i'm trying not to fall
maybe i'll have to stop recording once i
get down here just to turn on the light
flashlight and then take some photos but
oh wait no i won't be able to take a
still photo with it either
well the flash will but what am i
blabbing about
okay this is dark i can't see a [ __ ]
thing down here
yeah okay so i think i'm gonna totally
have to stop filming just to turn on the
light
that is cave dark i don't hear anyone
down here
i don't want to stop recording
okay i'm going to stop recording just so
i can see i'll be back with you shortly
okay so all i've done i'm right back
with you i just made it down to the
bottom
that's looking up from where i came from
because down here you can see a little
bit of a light
it's not showing up much for you but
it's not for me to see and this is
without a doubt the smallest tunnel yet
oh ow
just my back's not a big deal wow
this is a crawl almost i'm okay i had to
hit the
end of the record button like an idiot
but i'm saying there's a crawl i'm
squatting
very strong jimmy wow
what is this thing
what's up
close let's open it look at this where's
all this crap they have in here it's the
first thing i see
i should probably focus but if you walk
in and you see this thing
but okay will you flash a light down
there for
what what
i don't think that most of this is
showing up but it's something
let me see wow
i know that there's a terrible light
down here folks but
this is bigger than i thought the room
itself
and does it show you where this goes
it's just like i mean can you see where
it goes
wow oh wow okay let me zoom real quick
that looks like it goes a good
60 70 probably 60 something feet i don't
know
huh i'm not really sure that i'm not
really familiar
[Music]
and of course you got this angle down
here
and then all this wow
i gotta be careful this is a little bit
dangerous
well no wonder this light ain't doing
anything
[Music]
thank you like what is all this
will you just pan the light real quick
thank you so much
yeah i uh
what do you think yeah
yeah i left my camera back like a champ
or not my camera my my own torch my
flashlight
wow
just to get down in here with something
else we are deep
into the bedrock i forgot how deep this
is
i'll let you know in the video i'm
dripping sweat i haven't smelled like
this in a while
wow i think i'll stop recording because
i'm showing up but
i mean really what is this place
wow
above us has hundreds and hundreds of
feet of stone
well first a lot of bedrock trying to
remember how deep this is i want to say
it's 100
it's more than 100 feet down i think
under from the surface but
i'm just not remembering right right now
no it's not continuous
what else do you say
[Music]
all right let's pick the lock and go in
where's this lock
oh they got a good one on there that's
not something you think the door is in
itself
no you could probably no we wish
big
a tunnel i wish the lighting was picking
up better in here but it is what it is
so that might make it a little bit
better went to one bag
hi josh your first time down in here
yeah how was that trip down huh
yeah that last stretch of it was a
little tight i will admit
good thing it's down did that seem
like it was original did that seem
because it i mean it didn't look like it
was precision cut or anything
obviously some of it didn't i don't know
how deep are we again
do you remember that detail i'm trying
to believe what i'm feeling we're pretty
deep oh we're deep i know that
i just can't remember how many hundreds
of views
yeah hold on let's get the shot of this
you ready
don't touch
[Music]
yeah look at this i need the shot look
at that
look at that don't drop this one
i did but i had no view of anything
because it was so dark so i'm going to
follow you
with your outstanding light
all right i wish they'd take these big
boxes of crap out
okay so here we see
some cuts they look incredibly ancient
and you can see
crystallization on the stone
but with that said this fills with water
from time to time we are at a distance i
[Music]
oh really yeah
i've seen enough david attenborough
documentaries to know that
an abundance of life under the surface
guys you don't even know
including in the subterranean chamber of
the great pyramid of giza
i don't know what else to record this is
so dark down here but i'm just uh why
not record you know
i need a shot
[Music]
yes when you see these
bridges in
this is what's left of whatever it was
can you look at it it's broken and
destroyed
whatever it was because yeah but like
what part about this would be a tomb you
know it's just late bodies of
functionality
functionality what does that lose if you
think about the great part of the giza
that underneath it has some something
that seems somewhat functional the walls
are well
cut not like precision or anything but
it's
a task to do what they've done in here i
think you have
these waves in the stone it makes you
wonder
this isn't a tomb was it some resonance
chamber i think it had something to do
with resonance and they had something to
do with air
and water and vibration but i don't know
why there's a lot of theories
i know that i don't know and i know that
the to say that it was built
with the purpose of being a tomb doesn't
make any sense to me
and the only reason why people think it
is because that's what they were taught
and that's what they heard from the
get-go
as kids and when you have modern
academics
still repeating that people just because
this idea didn't even exist
until how long ago a bunch of invaders
came into this country
yeah and started coming up with ideas
that were
completely different from that of the
locals a lot of people don't realize
this
it's like 160 years ago these ideas
started floating around like oh that's
what it was
yeah there's an empty box there of
course it was a tomb that doesn't mean
it was built for that purpose and
there's nothing about it like people
think that
this is amazing supposed to distract uh
throw off tomb raiders i'm like that's
not the vibe i'm getting here
at least through those precise tunnels
and everything else and just like
now that i'm thinking about like the
grand gallery so-called grand gallery
i'm like there's nothing
ceremony about that there's nothing like
you don't realize just what a slant it
is i don't know what the angle is
i'll find out i want to say it's half of
i believe it's 26 degrees
because the great pyramid is 52 degrees
and i believe that that is exactly half
i'm almost certain now that i think
about it
but anyways the point is that there's no
steps there's no nothing it's not like
it's meant to just keep you out like oh
the tomb raiders would have slid down
and that's the end of it like guys
i because i know that even me saying
this and i'm gonna throw it on youtube
like i'll get a bunch of hate for it by
all these academics and people that buy
into the tomb theory i'm just saying and
no offense to anyone i just don't
that's not the vibe i'm getting here oh
you're not an expert you don't know what
you're talking about
all right fine all right i'm just saying
i don't think that that's what it is
i mean it's clear when you look around
here that i mean 100 it wasn't a tomb
which again
why would this be under here why would
there be tunnels going to it if it was
just a hole in the ground what is it a
well
is that the next theory yeah okay yeah
so instead of just
drilling a well which they did by the
way around egypt because they had to
live
um and obviously the nile was right
there too so why would you even need a
well
there's there's no real theory as to
what this is other than
the potential of and many people have
theorized about it that it
concentrates some form of
electromagnetic energy or some kind of
frequency
and we feel the resonance in the king's
chamber in the queen's chamber
and between near the grand gallery and
down here
you can definitely hear an echo and
this all just seems functional to me it
doesn't look
like it's built for any reason
to put mummies in it why would this be
here if the other if the other chambers
and we're seeing what's left of this
place after thousands of years of
she's my language [ __ ] people have
been
human beings have been going through
this place for such a long time
you don't know what they saw when they
first came in and this is just what's
left of it after it's been
rat aft i don't want to swear too much i
don't have to blur this
look bleep it out for the monetization
reasons but elsie's put it
nick were you gonna say something
brother yeah if you like
peek in there that's some equipment
they've got in there like what this is
what do you mean i'm not touching
anything
internet i'm just looking but the i got
some sort of uh
machinery to do some misery some sort of
stuff that i don't know
looks expensive i'm not messing with it
the interesting about me how do
you touch it touching it just looking at
it
let's see let's just see where do you
guys think this is
measuring tool yeah i don't think let me
see if i can smell yeah
dude that walk down here that hike that
that was something else
yeah and the last little bit of no light
and on dirt and through like dust
it was really dark too yeah i couldn't
see you you had your lights and stuff i
didn't
oh josh so he was in front of me
this jacket is killing me
about time for dinner no this is
something else
i just can't remember how deep you are i
know it's over 100 feet into bedrock i
just can't remember how far deep
and above us i believe it's 300 plus
feet to the king's chamber if i remember
right
and if i'm here nice and early hey if we
were quiet really quick i think we might
be able to hear them
yeah well i heard that from under here
you could hear ohms from
the king's chambers you know 300 or 350
feet above us
let's try it yeah
[Music]
oh hello hello alex
enjoy this place how'd you like that
hike down here not so much
you can see them lights flashing maybe
you can't
i guess i should stop recording [ __ ] i
just realized
yeah i'm at 13 minute mark but that
doesn't even include the other i have
two other clips
that were a bit long i had to hit the
off button just use my flashlight coming
down here
hold on